this past week in Bitcoin was a pretty
crazy one there's lots of stuff going on
outside of Bitcoin that are actually
having an impact don't forget that these
weekly updates are brought to you by FTX
click on the link in the description to
learn more if we start first by looking
at the metrics behind the Bitcoin
Network we can see that Bitcoin is
trading just below twenty thousand
dollars if we then go and look at the
market cap it's now sitting at 370
billion the inflation rates at 1.75
percent and the supply issued is just
over 90 percent the real exchange volume
is over 6.6 billion dollars in the last
24 hours and miners were paid 18 million
dollars in the last 24 hours as well
Bitcoin is down now 71 from its all-time
high and the gbtc discount is at 34
which is pretty wild Bitcoin is now
trading at 59 lower than it was one year
ago but gold and S P 500 are also down
in that same time frame over a two to
ten year time frame Bitcoin continues to
destroy those assets in price
performance as we sit now Bitcoin is
traded above the current level for 623
days which means that if you bought
Bitcoin for 87 of its life and held it
till today you would be in profit but if
you bought it for 12.45 of its life and
Hell till today you would be underwater
if we then compare Bitcoin gold S P 500
NASDAQ and TLT we see that bitcoin's
compound annual growth rate of 109 in
the last decade still is outperforming
these other assets and then the sharp
ratio over five years at 0.9 continues
to make it an attractive asset to add to
a diversified portfolio there's three
major stories that I think we should
call out in this past week the first is
that there was the merge in the ethereum
community many people in the Bitcoin
Community don't want to talk about it
they don't want to acknowledge that it
happened or they simply want to use it
to yell and scream about how it's not
going to work or it's some sort of scam
regardless of what you think about the
merge or its technical implications one
thing is definitely certain items like
the merge definitely have an impact on
the Bitcoin Market it brings
conversation to Wall Street and other
communities about crypto in general it
also takes away some of the excitement
about Bitcoin because people are looking
at some new shiny thing on top of that
it now pits Bitcoins proof of work
consensus mechanism with ethereum's
proof of stake regardless of where you
think it comes out there's now a line
drawn in the sand bitcoin's proof of
work as I believe will continue to
create decentralization and secure the
most secure Computing Network in the
world this Line in the Sand will lead to
all sorts of debate controversy and
hopefully Clarity around the differences
between these two different technical
architectures a second event that
occurred is that the White House's
executive order or on the study for
Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies finally
came out we see in this report all sorts
of craziness there's positives there's
negatives but what we do understand is
that the United States government is
continuing to push the idea of Central
Bank digital currencies they poke holes
and I ideas around Bitcoin ethereum or
other cryptocurrencies and they very
much like the idea of centralization and
having themselves in control that
shouldn't surprise anyone but what it
does do is it creates a Streisand effect
the more that the politicians The
Regulators and other positions of power
and influence continue to talk about
Bitcoin and the crypto industry it
brings more comfort in the Legacy
Financial world and also among
entrepreneurs and investors that
Streisand effect drives more and more
interest it makes people understand that
these assets are not going away it will
be here for years to come and then
lastly one week ago as of this Friday
Michael Saylor or microstrategy they
announced they were going to raise
another 500 million dollars via an
equity sale many people believe that
that 500 million dollars will be
deployed to purchase more Bitcoin so we
still have persistent bidders in the
market when you look at the totality of
the events that are unfolding in the
past week it is very easy to see the
Bitcoin is price is likely to not move
very much in the coming months but there
is still immense positive news whether
it's on the regulatory front whether
it's from persistent bidders or it's
simply from the continued build out of
Bitcoin the network whether that's
Mining Node operators or simply more
developers writing more code as we
continue to watch Bitcoin grow in
adoption one of the key statistics to
pay attention to is that the holder base
continues to hit all-time highs Bitcoin
has never been this ear liquid as David
pwell from Arc pointed out in my
conversation with them earlier this week
the Bitcoin ecosystem continues to
develop we'll continue every single
Saturday take a look at this make sure
that you go and check out FTX who now
sponsors these weekly updates they have
very cheap fees sometimes as much as 85
percent cheaper than their competitors
and they also have introduced digital
stock trading with no payment for order
flow and no transaction fees you can
learn more about FTX by clicking on the
link in the description I hope that you
enjoy these weekly updates as much as I
do and I'll see you all next Saturday